we're out here today to shoot down that
drone okay so this isn't your typical
target practice but these guys actually
have a pretty good excuse for firing
guns out in the middle of the desert
today we're testing a handful of drone
defensive products to see how well they
work this is Frances Brown he's a
managing partner at the cybersecurity
consultancy Bishop Fox where he and his
team look for new ways to defend against
digital threats and occasionally
physical flying ones too these days
they're researching ways to defend
against the growing problem of flying
BOTS that can represent everything from
a nuisance to serious danger dozens of
companies already offered drone defense
options but Brown says they're often
designed for the military like laser
weapons and radio frequency jammers or
they're just too expensive and
impractical not everyone has an equal on
hand we need some cost-effective more
practical we're in a range of solutions
and that brings us back out here where
his team is trying to figure out which
of these new gadgets is best at taking
down a rogue drone first we're gonna go
ahead and try the Skynet shotgun shells
which are 12-gauge shotgun shells that
have deploy a net specifically to try to
take down drones the Skynet shotgun
shells are one of the simpler drone
defense options available just twenty
dollars for three and they can be fired
from any traditional shotgun the
difference of course is the netting
which wraps around the drones propellers
to take it down the sky nets were
extremely effective to the cheapest out
of all the solutions by far from 70 feet
out it took them three to five shots per
drone number two we're gonna go ahead
and try to test these flashlight net
guns they look like a flashlight pull
them out of your belt up to 45 feet away
you can shoot them and take down drones
Brown tried to net guns one priced at
around seven hundred and seventy five
dollars and other at about five hundred
dollars
and this fire it's kind of dribbled out
here neither motto was quite prepared
for Arizona's 110 degree weather whether
it's mythbusted or not
we'll have to see it's not good for
Arizona or warm climates let's say that
for sure
lastly the piece de resistance the big
guy we have the sparrow hawk attached to
a huge DJI m600 drone and essentially
it's gonna be some air-to-air combat
it's going to try to go catch up to the
Dana drone with a really big net and
swoop it up to try to capture the drone
the sparrow hawk system is by far the
most expensive option Brown tested the
drone and the net system together come
close to around $11,000 we were able to
take down a drone pretty quickly and
fast so it's I think it's definitely a
good option very expensive option but
not for corporate security something
like that despite the failure of the net
guns in the Arizona Heat Brown says he
was surprised at how well the anti drone
tools worked say the surprise of the day
was probably the shotgun shells I
expected that they would do well but not
nearly as well as they did they were
super effective and the cheapest out of
all of the products that we tested today
but that doesn't mean they're meant for
everyone I would say the shotgun shells
are probably useful in certain scenarios
but they can be extremely dangerous
I think they could hurt somebody so I
think it would be extremely limited.and
where you can use them gonna be able to
use them in cities you won't be able to
use them in suburbs he notes that each
tool has a specific limited application
especially at long distances and that
means it could be years before
corporations first responders or even
governments are equipped with the tools
they need to deal with annoying or even
dangerous drums even then drone pilots
will likely adapt to circumvent
anti-drone systems in a continuing
cat-and-mouse game brown's tests show
there are real practical tools for
dealing with the coming age of flying
robots but these drone wars are just
getting started
[Music]